Welcome to the Berlin science
week and also a topic blog You can see
how the sea can help the climate here
I appreciate your interest and
I look forward to the next
hour and a half and the program for
the next hour and a half that is
shown here next to me and  My
name is Anne-Kathrin Lehmann, I am
from the German Allianz
Meeresforschung (d.a.m.) and I am in charge of
the office here in Berlin
and also the research department. Before
we get straight into the actual program
with these four exciting
lectures, I will give a brief overview
of why  marine research
is important and what the DRM is
and what the DRM actually does
and I'll start by
explaining that the ocean or
the oceans are the largest
interconnected ecosystem in the world and
they are of enormous importance for
life on earth  on the one hand,
they stabilize the climate, they regulate
the weather, they are habitats for a
large number of species, they store heat,
they absorb CO2 and much more and
the goal of marine research is to
gain knowledge
that can then be implemented in action
and I have here  As an
introduction to this slide, a few
reports brought along a few news
on marine research because
marine research is complex and so are
the topics and this is
basically where it starts with reports that
arctic more than further on the
retreat or the sea level is rising
locally and in the Baltic Sea
Of course, marine research also deals with the
condition of species and
of course there are reports that species
compositions are changing that
certain species are disappearing
it
also deals with looking or
discovering that things like plastic can
now even be found in a deep sea these
are all topics
of marine research and to
get to the bottom right you can see
the
core message actually from this one of
these topics slot  is that the seas
are essential for survival and
marine research is also
precautionary research precisely because it
provides findings that are then also the
basis for being
able to support sustainable development and that brings me
to the next slide I
just mentioned sustainable development
and I think that at least  For
most of you the Agenda 2030
is a term or the
sustainability goals of the United
Nations the so-called Sustainable
Development Goals sdgs which you can see
displayed on the bottom right and the
importance of the seas is also reflected
in these sdgs there is one goal
that is the SDP 14  that deals
directly with protecting the oceans that
includes things like
reducing pollution
reducing acidification protecting
species sustainable fisheries and so on so that
's a goal on the
sustainable development agenda and
of course that's not standing
alone here, it's with  linked to many other
goals, among other things, there is a very
close connection to the
climate goal that is SDT 13 climate protection
and the topic of today's event
is also called climate and more so these
two topics are very closely
interwoven and at the moment we are
in the so-called  The UN Decade of
Marine Research for Sustainable
Development began last year
and will run until 2030, which is why
the card says so, and it
arose from the realization
that far too little is being done at the moment
to protect the oceans and that much
more needs to be done  for the protection
and sustainable use of the seas,
coasts and oceans and the aim of this
un-dikade and the activities that
run under this umbrella is to
develop solutions in cooperation with
various specialist disciplines and in
cooperation with business, politics
and society because the implementation of the
sustainability goals  and the implementation
also of course that a
sustainability target protection of the seas
only works together
only works across borders and
only works in an interaction of
science, politics, society and
economy
and if you now think of the DRM of
the German Marine Research Alliance
then in principle the goal is sustainable
development  in principle also support
the core goal of damming and you can see that
here in an excerpt of the core goals
of the Diana it says we strengthen the
sustainable use of the coasts
several and ocean is as I said a
core goal of DHL
the DRM is the German
marine research alliance so it  is an
association of
marine research institutions throughout
Germany and the
German Marine Research Alliance was founded in 2019
jointly by
marine research institutions, there were
13 at the time and the federal government and
the five northern German states on the
map you can see the five northern German
states and we now have
23 members and  two strategic
partners and the members are very are
very diverse, so this includes
universities, these include
research institutes, museums and
authorities and the amazon
association and the aim of the association or of the association
is to bring the different
actors together to
establish a network and  then in principle to
also act in the sense of an association that
one is stronger together than alone
so that in principle one can achieve more as a
community of marine research
than it
would be possible for individual institutions
to be funded by the d.a.m. I have
already said it by the  Federal government
and the five northern German states
and what are the tasks
I could talk about for two hours
but I won't do it I'll try to
keep it short because there are
still
exciting lectures coming straight from
science and practice but I
want to go into that very briefly  have
four so-called core areas
main areas of responsibility one is
research I'll say something about that in a moment
the other is transfer that's
very important because it's about
conveying research results to
politics, society, economy and
entering into dialogue and that takes place
among other things  through events
publications
information portal and an
event like today here in the
Natural History Museum at the Berlin Science
Week is just such an element of
transfer to enter into a dialogue with
you,
two other subject areas that we
also only deal with very briefly are
data management and digitization and
infrastructures  that is directly
interwoven with research, of course,
you do research, you have
research data and the aim here is to
facilitate access and use of research data, this can be
done by having uniform
data management concepts, a
data portal in which different data is
collected  everything is fine, but
often they are just individual parts
and here it is a question of
linking
infrastructures with one another, as I said, also
essentially linked to research
here are a few pictures of
large seagoing devices, that's what they call it,
but much simpler or more understandable
than that  So it's
about underwater vehicles, for example, it's
about diving robots,
remote-controlled vehicles or
drills for the seabed,
these devices are usually on
individual facilities
are operated by individual facilities with
facilities and within the framework
of this association, it is also about being
accessible to all members
or to simplify access,
as I said, everything is closely intertwined
with research and later plays a major
role in the research missions, and
I would like to briefly
explain what
research mission means in general. These are long-
term projects. Research projects
and what is special is that  they focus on
current societal
issues at the moment we have
three two running one is planned and
a research mission is called
marine carbon stocks as a path to
decarbonization
what this mission does is it looks at
different measures how to
absorb CO2 in the ocean and
We can also hear more about this in two
lectures. There is a second
mission called Protection and Sustainable
Use. It looks at the protection and
use of Marian rooms. You
can imagine that there are of
course different
interests. There are protected areas
incredibly many forms of use
wind power tourism fishing and so
on it is
a challenge to reconcile that, we will
also hear something about it later in the
lecture and then a third mission is
planned with the state, probably on
January 1, 2024 is still a bit
of a topic  Marine extreme
events and natural hazards and that is
also what we have to
deal with here now more
because that is what is happening to us here too what is
special about this mission
is that it is interdisciplinary,
which means different
disciplines work together
natural
sciences engineering sciences
social sciences
political sciences
law and so on  further and
stakeholders are involved and that
is important because the goal
is also there to provide knowledge-based
options for action, so the
goal is basically to say,
for example, look at a specific
measure for CO2 storage
and then analyze what the
chances are  from a
social, from an ecological, from an
economic point of view, what are the risks,
what are the possible negative consequences,
also from different perspectives, and
that is important because then,
as I said, it is about
providing knowledge, enabling fact-based
decision-making options, in
principle telling politicians or other
decision-makers  okay if
you do that, that happens and that or that
could happen and then the
decision does not lie with science,
science ensures that
facts are provided that is in
principle the goal of the research mission
that is also the goal of the DN and that
’s basically me  also at the end
of the brief introduction and will
then, as I have already said, be happy to put it into
practice and
hand it over to science, and
with the first lecture I would like to welcome
Maria Elena Lagerh, she is
a geoscientist at the University of
Hamburg and will be us  In a
science slam,
she will present approaches to solutions for an emission-neutral future and she will also tell us what
is not a solution and I am very
excited and look forward to your presentation
[applause]
hello moin moin from Hamburg
so I still have the sound people a moment ago
not hit you're that
music will come up soon and you'd have to
turn it down a little but
you can do it
like this hi
I'm Elena I'm a
geoscientist and I'm holding a
science slam that means or the science
slam itself that means that's not a
solution and me  tell you something about
the my mineral olivine how it
dissolves in water how it binds CO2
and why that won't be the solution to the
climate crisis the olive that
is formed deep in the earth's mantle it comes to
the surface when it
is spewed out by volcanoes and weathered  or
dissolves but we do that when it comes into
contact with rainwater or
seawater. The olivine belongs to
the silicates, i.e. a silicon atom
is surrounded by four oxygen atoms and
these tetrahedrons then have
magnesium atoms
in between and they make the olives
so green and give  also his his
name
before i continue a quick question to
the group who got
an 5 in chemistry like me in school
very nice we probably share
the same trauma chemical
reaction equations and i can put your mind at
ease i found the secret
chemistry is like
swapping partners it  everything is much
easier than we think because after
the pandemic we are incredibly
bored and under-fucked and
now we go out again to party and that's how
it works in chemistry too
it's Saturday evening in Berghain or where
you go partying and enter the Olivin
the dance floor meets
four water and four
carbon dioxide molecules what happens
there is a lot of Berlin air and beer and
so on and it comes to that I
couple dissolve the magnesium becomes
single because the silicate
is having an affair with the hydrogen
and the other two are
doing it  still together as a bicarbonate whoever
was partying now knows towards the end of the
evening there is always a bit of Barry
White or George Michael all
people get romantic and that's what happens to
the magnesium and that asks
carbon and oxygen we
don't want to mix them up and they are totally
enthusiastic  am spontaneously a mineral and
that means magnet
and that is a love that
will last for many thousands of years
the silicate decides we want to
live monogamously now and forms opal and
what carbon dioxide want to go to the
next pub to dissolve further minerals there
what is now in this one  what is
important for you is that
only two of the four carbon dioxide and molecules
move on at the end of the evening, because the
fact that the olivine
has dissolved was able to form the magnetite and
this is where half the other half
of the CO2 is in it, i.e. CO2 comes from the
air  and goes into or becomes a
mineral, which means it goes back into the
geological cycle and if we
now dissolve a particularly large amount of olivine then we
will reduce the CO2 in the atmosphere
and thus have the main cause of the
climate crisis under control great
and now I have seven more  minutes
to explain why this doesn't
work
the olivine
takes a very long time to dissolve
a mineral one millimeter in size
takes about 2300 years to completely dissolve under
optimal conditions that
works faster when we have a higher
temperature a lower pH
or when  we make sure that the
surface of the mineral remains reactive
because over time a silicate crust forms with the solution
and brings the
reaction to a standstill and
we don't want that
and I've been researching this reactive surface
now I thought
well if we could use the olivine water  throw
and stir then not much happens
the olivine all olive grains move
in the same direction the
silicate crust can still form
in the reaction process we would prefer to
have something like this with a collision then the
silicate crust can always break open and such
and that’s why i
sent my off to Wacken on  Wacken like that
in a washing pad and the mosh pit in
my laboratory looked like this Wait a minute
I pumped more water through
this funnel and
by rubbing the olive grains
together I was able to dissolve the olivine faster
than if I
just  stir it or leave it in the water
and with this device, which is about as
big as I have calculated, I can
extract a ton of CO2 from the air in
2283 years with half a million
euros in electricity costs
and that is gross, but there are
emissions of electricity material  and
transport is not yet included so it
's not that practical
but we don't have to make it that complicated
because nature is very clever and does
it for us there
are many volcanic islands in this
world in the island of Hawaii and so on we
know it very well  and wherever
waves hit the beach da motion
they take the olive away day and night and
dissolve it that alone captures
three percent of our emissions each year
and feeds them back into the geological
cycle
and if i say okay i'd like
more of that i'll take  a handful of
olives throw it on the beach then it's
called the nature-based Gio Engineering
hooray that's this Gio Engineering
that everyone is talking about
and or also negative emissions because
we have imitated something and
we are now actively bringing it back that is
forbidden
and we have to  but also asking the question
is it really necessary that
we pull emissions out of the
atmosphere again we could
just do a bit better
climate protection and to
understand that I brought my colleague
along nelly saved many
years ago about global warming
and here  explain how
it works in climate science the
story behind it
Foyer found out in 1824 that the earth
was much warmer than it
should be he had found the greenhouse effect
UNICE Newton food points out
that CO2 is an important greenhouse gas
John Kindle passes the short  Time
later this realization and as a man
he went down in history for it.
20erinius was the first to calculate what
the atmosphere is called if you
double the CO2 in it. At that time
you thought you would harvest great weather and
suggested burning even more coal
through the people around you
this dude found out in the 30s
about 100 years ago that the
earth was really warming up and even
then people still had a very, very
positive picture of this warming in
the 50s Charles David started killing
To measure and record CO2 and
draw very clearly that we
humans and our emissions
are the cause of the climate crisis in the
60's yes in the 60's oil companies were
so they could melt 7 million tons
of glaciers a day now
we're at 320 times that in the 70's
economists stated that it was a really
stupid idea to let unlimited growth
take place on a limited earth
and exon mobile prophesied to us
how [ __ ] up our climate
would be today if they had not deliberately withheld their information
the founding of the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Change followed in Rio Kyoto
and the Paris conferences  Agreement and nothing absolutely
nothing has led to there being a
global strategy for climate protection
that is actually being implemented
emissions are increasing and increasing
it is actually much worse
because there are still people who ask
how much climate protection should actually
cost or because  today is such a day let
's not change politics right away
I can tell you what no climate protection
costs us today
the arid ones get longer every year the
heat waves get hotter the storms
get stronger and the floods get
higher
no climate protection costs us our belongings
our peace  and our lives
and there are still smartasses who
mean eight plants just a
few trees and they still have
n't understood that the earth burns and that
it burns and burns and burns and burns and burns
and burns and
burns
that is the acquisition of  only 1.1 degrees
and we will all
experience twice as much, probably triple and
when this century was born
four to five times
what can we do about it
we are so late with
climate protection that we really only have
one strategy left that exists
from two points the first point is we
have to reduce our emissions by 90%
that is non-negotiable
and for this we need all politics
industry and also each individual because
90 percent less means that our
electricity production heat mobility our
food and above all consumption
look completely different  I'm
talking about less of much much much
less of everything
the second point of this strategy is
that we will always have emissions that
we cannot avoid and this is where
olives can be a solution along with
direct aircatcher capture or planting
charcoal or bogs or afforestation  and so
on but many technologies are
in their infancy we don't even know
if we can successfully implement them
and they are ridiculously expensive they
cost money they cost water resources
and as I said we are researching it but
we still can't do it
that doesn't mean that olivine  is the
solution to the climate crisis you are the
solution to the climate crisis because if you and
I are not there and support these 90
percent emission reductions
then I don't have to
do any further research because then my
research on olivine will no longer have any influence
politics has us scientists 200
Ignored for years and that's why
I would like to ask you not to wait any longer for laws
but to start with climate protection yourself
you know exactly how it
works
because otherwise we will lose everything we
have
Thank you for your attention and
if you don't always just hear problems
want to get rid of it  there is also a book about
solutions from February next year
I picked apart problems together with eleven science students
and
wrote about solutions and thank you
very much [
applause]
thank you Maria Elena for the
insight there are questions from the audience
we have time for a two  short
questions
the mean thing is what i showed
that is the idealized
solution reaction in real life
often only one step happens so that means
we all drink on the dance floor and
the CO2 stays in the water in the sea in the form of bicarbonate for
a very long time it can be
up to  Swimming around for 100,000 years
or it is used by organisms to
form calcium carbonate magnesied
actually only occurs at high
temperatures but for understanding
I have now shown that
this is but so if we only
have the first step of this reaction
it is actually very very good because
on the one hand, the pH value of the sea is
increased because it becomes more acidic,
so that is a positive effect and,
on the other hand, the bicarbonate
that I form as a result can
serve as a basis for the formation of lime shells
and also for the organisms that form lime
in the sea, they also suffer from the
acidification of the sea and that is
good for them,
so in geosciences we learn
that not only Uli Wien
but many other minerals weather during our studies
and consume CO2 and
pure olivine can be found quite well in
Norway and  in other volcanic
areas also in the Eifel there are
by the way here in the in the museum there
are also a few pieces of olives in the
collection we ourselves so I have now
changed my field of research we
no longer throw it into the sea we
throw it on the field and there  we do
n't take olivine but a rock, which
means that it contains several minerals
and they also bring additional
nutrients to the plants and they
also dissolve in them, while
at the same time consuming CO2, which means that
you can only get pure olivine
in specialist shops  For
example, you could buy basalt powder that goes
by the name of eifelgold you can find it in the hardware store
and you can sprinkle it in your garden
and then you have beautiful flowers and the
climate is made a bit better
I said it was a great presentation
a big compliment but I guess
times that there are only people sitting in this lecture hall
who can also do something with the
climate crisis, what if what
could we all do who are
sitting or science
to motivate the others who are not sitting here better, they only eat
cheaper meat  want to eat and yes and
yes so I don't need to list the examples to
motivate them to participate more here too
that we always ask yes that's
a great question for
social and social sciences in particular
and I'm very happy that I'm
studying natural sciences
server we can do
climate protection on many different levels
we can make a difference privately
and that doesn't just mean I
'm going vegetarian now, but
that we talk a lot more about it in our environment
say that the climate crisis
has been going on for a long time that I've
been here for a long time because for many it's
still far away we can also
take it to the outside world that means, for
example, to the workplace we can
think about how my company or or
my my  Commuting to work or something like that, how can
the climate be made more climate-friendly,
how can my community be made more climate-friendly,
and then you can
always take a step up until at
some point you stand in the Bundestag
with people, so there are many, or I
experience it when many
people give lectures that unsettle them  are the sayings
I've heard it's natural and
others said it's not
natural the warming and it's
actually very easy to convince these insecure people by simply
clarifying these fundamental questions, so no, it
's not the sun's fault  doesn't shine
brighter that's why it gets warm but it
comes from the
greenhouse effect and things like that and there
is a very small but hard and
unfortunately also very loud core that is
similar to lateral thinkers who
claim exactly the opposite and with
whom I mean waste  Time not
that so they are fact-resistant, that is to
say, convincing is useless, it
would only be important that you protect the people
who are in the area that you protect them a
bit from
offering him talks and
offers to enlighten them and that completely
neutrally without personal attack  because it is
precisely this personal attack, I
think we also
noticed during the pandemic that as soon as
people feel personally attacked,
you no
longer have access to them with arguments
and yes, what you can do
really on all levels, that is
not only to do something for oneself but
in the family on the street and so
on and not everyone
owns a company but there are
people who found the company and
then have five employees or so and
you can do a lot by
doing that  you just
make a very clear statement and as it says we
are a climate-neutral company
or we do without this and that we
have an event where there is
of course a vegetarian buffet,
so things like that and it is
just natural to
act in a climate-friendly way rather than
harmful to the climate  acting is far
too easy
thank you Maria Elena again for your
lecture and in the next lecture we will hear
another solution for
an immission-neutral future and
I would like to welcome Martin Zimmer for that
Martin Zimmer is a
professor at the Leibniz Center for
Tropical Marine Research he heads the
working group mangrove ecology and the
is a professor at the University of Bremen
and he will soon tell us about the sense and
nonsense of planting trees
thank you
so much for the introduction thank you
for the invitation I am
also happy that so many listeners are here today
olivia is green we stay green  I would
like to tell you something about the meadows
and forests of the seas, i.e. salt marshes,
bare seagrass meadows or tank forests and mangrove forests
and how these
can possibly make a part or a contribution
to the problem that Elena has just
mentioned. In addition,
of course we all want to and have to make contributions,
climate change  it's clear what's happening
we just heard it's a
different form of representation that we're
seeing here and we're seeing that it
's been felt very clearly for a few decades now for 40 45 years it
started a lot earlier but in the
last four or five  For decades,
the average annual temperature has
always been higher than the long-term mean
of the previous century
the math the
chemistry everything behind it what happens the
physics in the atmosphere and we can
even predict exactly how much CO2 is
allowed in the atmosphere if
we accept a certain temperature limit
we see that here on the
horizontal and vertical lines the
1.5  The goal of the political
negotiations is quite clearly somewhere
just below 3,000 gigatons of CO2
in the atmosphere, the two-degree goal
is somewhere in the range of
three and a half to 4,000 gigatons, so
we know exactly where the problem
lies
and we know exactly that we are
doing something about it and against it  we have to do something
we just heard it the nice thing is
we can do something
we can still do it
i'm very optimistic and very convinced
that it's not so nice we have to
do it now we should have
started the day before yesterday but
today at the latest  do we
actually have to do it the only question is what
can we do we can all
go over to the museum and the
exhibits together and throw tomato soup with it
about how useful it is and what
contribution it makes to climate protection
can certainly be argued about
but
we can stop  to breathe then
we no longer emit any CO2 the success
is probably not much
greater than the climate throwing tomato soup at
the exhibits so we can
give it to ourselves so what can
we do when these very
simple options are no longer an
option  come and we just heard that from
Elena, first of all,
we simply have to change our behavior,
we have to save CO2 as the driver
of climate change, first of all,
we have to reduce our energy consumption,
we maybe have to
stop constantly using our cell phones on the
internet that maybe  Then
my message to the younger
generation too, we have to change our consumption, our
consumer behavior
Vegetarianism is one possibility, but
there are other things that can also help
and of course we can change our
energy production, we have to change our idea of
production to sustainable
energies to non-fossil energies that are
simply less
Blowing CO2 into the atmosphere and
possibly even being CO2-neutral,
but that won't be enough.
We've heard that before, if
we assume a very optimistic picture of
saving 90 percent of emissions, the ten percent that
are left are still too much and  we
have to counteract the
negative emotions
we just heard that really
just means that we have to remove more CO2 from the atmosphere
than we put into the atmosphere through our
behavior through energy production and
the like
how can we do that
olivine if we take our time
could be a solution we are trying
to find other solutions Ms. Lehmann
just mentioned the DRM mission
cdamare I only have time
to go into one of the aspects here and that is also
the aspect that I am most familiar with,
but we are working in one  in a
consortium on a large mission
to compare which of the possibilities
that we know today, technically or naturally,
would be the best and the result is actually
already clear to us. none of these methods
alone will be sufficient, it will be
a combination of many approaches of many
methods act and probably
all these methods will have to
come we have to be willing to
accept that we stay with
the meadows and forests of the seas
CO2 as a gas in the atmosphere is captured by
the vegetation
invested in the growth of the plants and then
we have one  Tree, shrub or
seagrass standing around somewhere and there
CO2 is fixed in the biomass for
a certain period of time so far it is
the same on land in forests on
meadows and by the sea in the salt marshes
in the seagrass meadows in the mangrove
forests the difference in the
coastal areas  of coastal ecosystems
mangrove forests seagrass meadows
salt marshes kelp forests is
that we don't break down the organic
material that accumulates there in the trees
and falls on the ground in the same way
as it does on land
and that's not just the material
that comes from the forests or from the
Seagrass meadows themselves come from what is
accumulated there but also
material brought in from the outside by
the tides from the sea through the
rivers from the hinterland and all that
accumulates in these structures
remains there for a long period of time is
covered by sediment and animals enter
it  Sediment is drawn into the soil into the
subsoil and this
subsoil is oxygen deficient or even
oxygen free and under these
conditions
the processes leading to degradation leading to the
release of CO2 take place
much more slowly if at all i.e.
in these systems
organic material becomes organic
carbon  So in the end CO2 has
been determined quite stably over a long period of time
how stable exactly how long exactly these
are all still open questions that
we are working on
I just showed him that the
CO2 the CO2 emissions are very much lower compared to the
other systems
In this coastal ecosystem,
this means that compared to the
terrestrial systems on the left, 3
forest systems from the tropics, the
temperate and subpolar areas and
on the right, 3 coastal ecosystems,
salt marshes, mangrove forests and
seagrass meadows. This means that
many times
more CO2 is stored in the coastal systems on the right every year
and as I said there remains relatively stable according to
current knowledge,
the nice thing about it is that when we
look at these ecosystems, they not
only potentially counteract climate change
because they bind CO2, they
also have many numerous
side effects, similar to those
in the package insert of their medication
the mostly negative side effects
but here we have positive co benefits
we call that and that is
another argument for us
to research in this direction and to consider
how and where and with what means
we can promote these ecosystems to
counteract climate change
and  then also the positive
side effects for us and for the
people on site to use
is the solution kissed to
plant vegetation as I said the solution does
not exist anyway there is only one of
several the problem is that it often just does
n't work we know
relatively today  well what you actually have to
do but in many cases it is
not done because it is
more effective for the media to simply put
large amounts of plants
somewhere in the Wadden Sea in large groups and
if you come back six months
they are gone or dead
but that doesn't change the fact that it
is still common and we
just have to keep looking and keep
working to really improve these methods of
planting and to
make sure it's
done in a sustainable way it can look like this
if you do it sensibly after a
few years these are all little
saplings they are  are three four years old
but within 15 20 years they have
grown and are healthy
climate to
climate change medication we
need to understand where the planting and
the expansion of the areas is possible
where it makes sense which species
are suitable in which locations and
certainly it is very different
whether you look in the German Baltic Sea or the
German North Sea we look at
it  also in the tropics on the
Caribbean
coast of Colombia or in Malaysia
there are completely different systems that
grow there and they have different
properties and we have to
consider which of these systems
are the best but of course also what
are the consequences of these
plantings for society  for
the local people what about
the acceptance are the
people ready that we want to plant in a region where
maybe there could also be beaches with hotels call
stinky snake
call someone the people
we can convince you that that is good and
then  of course the question what does it do
at all is it such a
strong remedy at all we just heard it from
a very urgent that
well it really helps we do
n’t know to find out we are on
behalf of the DRM and the ministry
and
crawl through them  now I always have to make sure
that I turn off my alarm clock
and crawl here through the mangroves
and take sediment samples and bring
these samples to the laboratory and examine
them there, it's not yet in the laboratory, so
we just prepare them and examine
them there for their properties  we
get dirty, we sweat in the
sense of science, but we
also have fun and
I think that's also very important and I think it's
also important for us not to
forget to say we have fun, even if we
can find out more about it, it's fun too
thank you for your
attention and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much Mr. Zimmer also to you for
the insight into the research there are
questions about it
if you wait a second you
'll get a mic then I understand you
better yes
hello I disagree with you  not
like they are trying to fight the CO2, so to speak,
but I find it
completely wrong that everything is based on CO2
that is only one component
greenhouse effects are much broader because
some sprinkle the water has 9
times more
greenhouse effects and you pounce on
this CO2 and in connection  with the
CO2 it always has something to
do with combustion you completely negate
the energy
you notice CO2 on the train the
temperatures on the train the code with the
CO2 a lot of energy is
used to heat up our earth, so to speak,
and that is simply
ignored there  just becomes CO2 and
I'm telling you that's the wrong way
to just bet on that one component
we're not just betting on that one
component you're absolutely right Water
plays a big part Water plays
a part than
water vapor in the atmosphere Clouds
are a lot more important  Factor in the
warming and in the reflection of heat
from the earth's surface back to
the earth's surface, but we can influence the
water content of the atmosphere relatively
poorly, but we can
influence CO2 and other greenhouse gases such as methane or nitrous oxide very well, we
talk primarily about CO2 because
that is the most important component of our
energy production and our consumption
Methane and nitrous oxide are much
stronger greenhouse gases that is absolutely
correct, but we have a
much smaller influence on this through our
behavior and,
incidentally, we also understand much less
about how these are produced and under what
conditions  these gases are
used, I agree with you that it
might not be wise
to focus only on the CO2, but as I said,
this is the moment we have the lever that we have in our
hands where we can most easily
turn a setting wheel and
can expect great effects
here  the er de
the sun's energy comes to earth whether
we set up solar panels or not,
so we don't increase the
solar radiation with that,
yes, but it is the sunlight
that we reflect back through the mirrors
is deflected back into the atmosphere,
among other things, by
clouds or by
water molecules  in the atmosphere that
have exactly this effect this mirror
idea is another possibility
to make a contribution if necessary it is being
discussed it is being
tried out on a small scale but
the point is that all of this alone wo
n't do anything we just have to put the CO2 in
reduce the atmosphere what we blew in there
that means it's our
own fault and it's up to us
to undo this mistake
I have a question regarding the
mangrove planting so you
said that a lot of seedlings are washed away
or what strategies are there
to protect them
that is a very good question on the one hand one
cause is simply that they are
planted in the wrong place
either on a wrong coast where too
strong currents are in the wrong
place in the tide in the shown
areas of the intertidal zone because
of different mangrove species
colonize different habitats
that the subsoil that they
are simply not suitable for humans because
it is too coarse-grained to offer these little
plants a home what we do
about it is clearly knowing
which species grow best where
and if we
mangroves or others
want to spread coastal plants there want to settle there
where the currents may
not be ideal the bad word of
Gio Engineering comes into play again what he
heard then you would have to
build bamboo fences in the water at least for a short time to keep the coastal current around the
waves for a certain time  Time to
tone down for a few years and to ensure
that the young plants
are largely undisturbed until they
are anchored firmly enough in the sediment and
then, even after we have removed the fences,
to be able to grow again accordingly,
but then we come to the problem of
what exactly you  you just mentioned
it is not so welcome that we
intervene so actively in these natural processes
time for a short question please we still have
economy we all know how tourism
economy works with the beach
what is there can you think of place
there is  a whole range there is
honey production in many regions
there is very sustainable
shrimp fishing where the fishermen
know very well how long they
have to wait before they can go back to the same
area to fish the shrimp
timber industry can be very sustainable
there are good ones  Examples of this in Malaysia,
for example, where since the wood is processed into charcoal,
i.e. charcoal grill charcoal is
processed, that is certainly
not sustainable, but if you were to
use it, for example, to produce furniture
or wooden construction in the building industry,
the CO2 would also be in the biomass for decades or longer
split
I could imagine that would be a
good solution
wonderful thank you again for this
insight into the research
from us and that
brings us to the next lecture
this is about the effects of
climate change on certain species and
I would like to welcome David Drewes for that
He is an oceanographer and doctoral student at the
Helmholtz Center Hereon in Geesthacht
near Hamburg and he takes us
on a search for the stint I do
n't think he's here in the Spree,
but David will tell us that again,
please
Hello from my
side I'm David and yes today it's
about the question where is the stint the whole thing
is part of my doctoral thesis that I'm writing in the
project course features that's
also part of the research missions that
dirm I myself am in Hamburg have
us  Landed in the center here and a bit
outside of Hamburg and yes
if I were to hold the front Hamburg
I would tend to
assume that everyone here in the room
knows the right one most people have it
there after one or the other
party night at the harbor with the fish
prevents seen
but for you the very short
profile at the top left the picture 10 to 15
cm long when the parts are fully grown
and the special thing about these fish
why they are so interesting for us
is that they are migratory fish if we
look at the North Sea coast
the adult fish live here
in front of the areas
on the coast in the salt water and when it
gets a bit colder in winter
they start to move into these checkered
hatched areas and then
in spring they move up the three river runs of EMS
Weser and Elbe and there
lay their eggs and the young fish
then grow up in the areas and
then in the course of their lives
also move back out to the coast so that I
repeat the life cycle over and over again
come and
one of the fishermen offers it to
buy I don't expect you to
recognize it from the picture but feel free to touch the fish
if your fish if your
fingers smell very very penetratingly of
cucumber afterwards you have
actually caught the right fish
I have  I tested mine in Bremerhaven myself
and you got the smell of cucumbers
on your fingers for a few days,
but why is the smell so
special and why is it so interesting,
especially for us when it comes to
looking at the extent to which species
are affected by climate change here, it is a
so-called key species  in other words,
if we look at the food chain in the
ecosystem of these rivers, there
is always somewhere in the middle
between the plankton from which it
feeds, which is the basic food for everything,
and the higher hunters such as
fish or seals, which feed on the smelt,
if there is anything  somehow
breaks apart in this chain that always has
consequences for the entire ecosystem
when we talk about research, however, it is
also nice if you have long-term observations of an
animal species and especially certain
animal species for
the stinks have been around for 20 years
in the Hamburg area for  the Elbe this
monitoring at different places there
is always fished and
looked at how much is there in the
last one um there is a lot of
variability in there you can
imagine that when a fisherman
fishes there sometimes more fish out sometimes less
there  now not always well the
average reached but just a
completely normal trend over the last few
years you can see what the
stocks are concerned also very very
important for public relations and
for attention is always when the
fish is used as a delicacy and
that happens in  Hamburg very very often
most fishermen sell a lot in
restaurants, especially in spring,
and can also draw a lot of
attention when it comes to the fact
that the stocks are slowly
becoming unstable and that's exactly where the problem lies
with the right and how do you find the  It's
best to find out that there is a problem
if you
're not a scientist and know how to
ask, you just do a
Google search and look for
newspaper articles and I actually did that at the
beginning of my doctoral thesis,
you'll find articles  like
this one from the Süddeutsche Zeitung
the environmentalists see the
killer in dredgers on the Elbe the federal government
reports on a new report on the
standing decline and if you
look at the WWF it says very
clearly that the voice stocks are out in the
open, especially in the tidal areas of the Elbe
Fall and as reasons for this they say the
Elbe is always overflowing and these
constant interventions, also due to the
deepening and all the structural
measures in the Elbe, are meanwhile taking the
ecosystem to the limit if
we look at the whole thing in a very
simplified way at some
river somewhere  in the world we can
also take the Elbe as an example what
are the influences we have on the
one hand are the man-made
influences so-called anthropogenic
influences when you think of Hamburg I
bet you most of you immediately have
the port in mind somehow and the
Whole ships that go in
and out of there every day, the factories
that use the water as cooling water and and and
and and whenever it is
used economically,
we are also in the area of
structural changes, so
a new plant has to be built here  or
somehow in Hamburg, the entire
Elbe has to be dredged further towards the North Sea
so that ever larger
ships can call at the port,
but we also have things that
happen on a much, much longer scale,
namely things that
somehow change this ecosystem as a result of climate change and
we  have already seen it in pictures
of Elena this summer
has shown us very clearly what kind
of changes these are we have
less and less fresh water in the rivers
due to less rain but also due to
less melt water from the
inland areas and we have a constant
rise in temperature all  for
such an ecosystem, that is something that it
first has to adjust to as that leads to
changes and for Hamburg the
changes are very easy to see
and of these four influences that I have
always shown, the two main
consequences of this are extreme
turbidity of the water  The picture was
actually taken at the beginning of this week
when I was at the port again
to do it. You can
consider whether you would like to spend a beach holiday with us
in the port of Hamburg.
I would tend to
advise him against it. You no longer see your hand in front of your face
when you  Going diving
is really uncomfortable and you can
imagine if you don't see anything
such a small fish does
n't really see anything that's swimming around in front of its nose
with all the sediment
that's being whirled up, we've
covered the second problem right away  there is
also a lot of dead stuff in there and
this dead stuff has to be decomposed
and that needs oxygen, which means
this summer in the
Port of Hamburg in fact there was hardly any oxygen in the water in the entire
area of ​​the Port of Hamburg
and if you
think about it, there were also fish  They
need oxygen well they just suffocate
miserably in these areas because they do
n't have the strength to
swim out of it but where does that affect that right well
we have the eggs
their eggs are laid on the ground in the
coastal areas but those are also
nice places  where the diggers
drain their mud they then lie on
top of the eggs, that means we have many
eggs that can no longer hatch
if we continue in the life cycle as
small larvae, these fish are very,
very quickly dependent on
finding food without moving around themselves
can that means you have to open your mouth at the right
moment and
snap it only works if
you can see that the food is there at all
due to the turbidity this is not
possible at the same time we have the
lack of oxygen which can
now very often be observed in the elevator areas
That means that most of the
sting larvae that have already hatched do
n't even get into this last
phase in which they are more or less fully
grown and even then who
thinks they've finally
made it nope, let's continue then the
consequences can be fungal diseases
due to clogged gills and and and  That
means that
these fish are no longer safe in the Elbe in any phase of their life
or have a high chance of survival
and then the question arises what can
we actually do we could now do
a lot in geoingen,
too, you could certainly find things there,
but we can also do that for now
take our model and
turn on our computer and look in a virtual
environment what makes
sense where do things are without
further straining nature and
testing something and ideas that we
have since developed while,
for example,
setting up protection zones or
quiet times there  could you test where you
can do that best without having to
test it out right away where there is always a
certain amount of effort behind it
you look for ways to
reduce the causes of this fish or just the non plus
ultra meadows partly in the Ems and in
the Weser is already being done and
research is being done, where an artificial
settlement of populations
must now be considered because the
population itself is no longer
capable of reproduction and would otherwise
simply die out in the next few years
and I just
brought one of our models with me as an example here,
pretty colorful  these are always our pictures
you don't have to
look at them that closely it just shows how accurate
we can model and in the lower
area you can see the port of Hamburg
with all the side areas and
all the sides of the berths for the
ships, which means we can use one
Resolution of about 5 meters
horizontally dissolve the port and
carry out structural changes and
test the extent to which this affects the
entire life cycle of the voice
because we are
now able to
parameterize it mathematically and simply use
simple equations to determine the life of
such  of a fish species if
we then incorporate all this into this model,
we can see to what extent
all this will change in the future and
what solutions might be available so that we
in the Elbe can continue to support this
one fish species as an example for all
other fish species
that we can  they will be with us for a longer period of time
and yes we hope that we will be
successful with that and to answer the question
where that is correct
the stint is still there but it will be very,
very tight and we have to
act very, very quickly to keep it that way
and with that thank you for your attention thank you
very much David for your lecture I do
n't know about you but I
learned something again and you
certainly have questions
or comments
hello thank you very much for this great
lecture which was really very
informative and also the
connections very much  well showed what
it looks like in concrete terms, so you
have now developed these suggestions as to what
you can do, what you can try out,
you definitely have to talk to the
city of Hamburg and
talk to the port, do you do that
or do you suggest it to them?  what's
the response like how does something like that work we
actually
have to take a step back we have to
get this model up and running with all that first of all it's usually a
bit of work, as I said, these are
just ideas so far and we
just want to test them out,
but actually  yes, the city of Hamburg
who was certainly the first
point of contact there already existed or
there are other protected areas for other
fish species where you
could actually see very clearly that this
has helped the stocks in the long term because
then dredging in these areas is no
longer allowed  At certain times
and also around it, nothing more can be
done to protect the young fish in particular
and then it will be exciting with whom we will
certainly
somehow get into conversation with you and
bring it to the public, which is
also a large part of our
I'm just doing a research mission from the side well are
there any further questions yes
you showed us this plate with the
breaded and grilled stink
and said that the fishermen there in the
spring I think
bring in quite a large amount I can
imagine that that  necessary I mean
if the fish is 10 cm then you have to
turn over a whole lot of food
but where do they get it from when
we have such a big problem that the
stink is actually hardly to be found anymore
so the Stinfischer had it around before
a lot easier meanwhile they
really have problems
getting that much fish on the table
and in hamburg so if you
look at the classic tuning restaurants
most of them are closed by these fisherman families
i think there are
now of the 12 this time there were only  there are
still three left and even they are considering
switching to other types of fish because they can no longer refinance it from the stink alone
and they also do
pre-orders so you have to pre-
order in advance in the forest so that they then
have the fish there so you have this idea
just drives there and gets
his portion right from there that does
n't work anymore and it's actually
like that when we look at these statistics
the fish are no longer
becoming active but only as
bycatch statistics in the monitor there was just so
little there is one thing  own monitoring
trip only for this fish species no
longer makes any sense in any of the three
rivers there
are no further questions we have time
for a short one there
is another one I'll come to him
the port of Hamburg is really
I think one of the most active help
how does it look  compared to the
other two it's even
better there or is that also from the same
way down
so as I said in the other
rivers Ems and Weser it
actually looks worse mean
that the tune institute in Bremerhaven
Forst meanwhile has it like them  Being
able to raise fish in the laboratory and being able to
release them, because around
Bremen the voice stocks
have declined so much that they
are no longer preserved,
things are still looking good in the Elbe
more or less
then thank you again David for
your exciting lecture and with it
we have already reached the last lecture
and for that I welcome Luisa
von albedill, she is more than a physicist
from the Alfred Wegener Institute for Polar
and Marine Research in Bremerhaven and
she takes us on the journey of what is
probably the
largest research expedition of the type
of  expedition of all times and she will
explain to us in a moment how it is
to research between ice ridges and gullies
and i think it will be adventurous please
yes thank you very much i am very happy now
in the last lecture to take you again to a very
special place
and that is to the arctic  into a
beautiful, unique and somewhat
special world that is changing like no other region in
the world due to climate change
and to get you in the mood for the
lecture topic I
brought a noise for you and a
picture let's start with the noise
do you have any idea what  You just
heard that it has something to do with the
ice ridges that you can see here in
this picture, namely
blocks of ice that
pushed over each other to produce these ice ridges that
are like small icebergs, actually yes,
so that's where
the
ice floes slide  pile up
on top of each other and form these
ice ridges we can maybe hear that again
the noise
in contrast to what many
people initially expect, the Arctic is
neither a completely quiet place like we
just heard nor is it
a completely flat one  So different
from the sea ice that we
know from ice skating, the
arctic ice consists of more than ridges
and gullies, which I have highlighted here
with yellow hatching,
which means there is quite a lot of
chaos, quite a lot of different
processes at work and they are  very
crucial for the Arctic and that's why
I'm going to go into that in a bit more detail in a moment,
but let's start with another
global look at the
temperature rises, which we
've already heard so much about  The
place is and
the temperatures in the Arctic are warming up three
to four degrees
more than they are here and here
you can see a little bit that
you can see the temperature distribution for
the year 2021 somehow Arctic also
see it is shown in red colors
where we just had a temperature anomaly
of four degrees compared to
1951 to 80 this year 2021 was nothing
special but was actually just
one of many years in the last ten
years that show a
bit of the warming stripes of the arctic
you see at the bottom  on the foil
where you can also see in colors how
the temperature anomalies are in the
Arctic and you can see that in the
last 10 years the scale is actually not
even sufficient to really
depict the warming, i.e. this
global warming that we are already
experiencing here  is a lot stronger in the arctic
it doesn't leave the arctic unscathed
as a result the more than
cover so the frozen ocean changes quite
dramatically this is a graphic that
many may have already seen in the
newspaper where you can see how
the more  as coverage has decreased in the last
40 50 years
maybe stop for a moment
and ask yourself where you will be in 30 years
maybe you have
somehow achieved your desired position in the company maybe you
are maybe retiring
maybe you will have children
or yours  Children are already working
maybe there will also
be grandchildren 30 years is about the current
horizon where ours is more and
climate models predict that we will
not have more than more in the Arctic in summer
that is still a
long time but I think everyone
can roughly imagine  how
these 30 years
will perhaps pass by themselves and I'm
probably the last generation
more than researchers who
actually saw more than in the Arctic in the summer,
that's of course it has an impact
on the climate system in the Arctic,
but it also has an impact on  us here
in the lower latitudes because through
atmospheric circulation we are
really directly connected to the arctic
and the increase and change in
our weather here is strongly related
to that, the same is true on
much longer time scales with the
connection to the ocean as well  Here
it is the case that the changes in the
Arctic mean that in the very
long term we will also have changes in the
heat transport in the ocean currents.
All of this is reason enough to explore the Arctic more
closely to better understand the processes there
and that is
not the case at all  simply because the Arctic is a
bit of a white spot of
science it is there are very
harsh living conditions there we have
little light it is cold and that is why
we simply do not have large
accumulations of people there that
long-term observation studies
could provide us with that are missing and
especially  there is no data from the
winter because very little has been researched there so far, yes
on expeditions,
that is
particularly important because the Arctic, in
contrast to yes at our latitudes, is
richer by one component in the climate system here, we just have that more than the
how  there is a cover between the atmosphere and the
ocean and shields everything a bit and
we just want to
understand this better so that we can model it
correctly in our climate models and then
be able to make realistic predictions later
this is this triad was definitely the
goal  Our mosaic expedition
Mosaic was probably the really big
research expedition
for this decade, definitely
the biggest we have ever experienced where
we spent
a year in the Arctic with a research icebreaker in 2019/2020,
the ship Polarstern was frozen
or has frozen
like that is a passive with the
transpuller hits one
drifted in the ice for a year in an ice current and the numbers that are
mentioned here capture the person perhaps a
bit of the superlative that
this expedition really represents,
so for us it is a  Huge
milestone and one aspect of it
I would like to show it again briefly
what we just
took a closer look at we are
fortunately finally back on the ice and
ours with the ice ridges and the channels
and how they would actually get into the ice
i  I would like to show you with this film you
can
imagine you are now standing on the
Polarstern and experience in fast motion what
we experienced there
that would be the picture that you can see the egg
is that at first seems totally stable
it is not at all but it moves  are
constantly driven
apart and back together by wind and ocean currents,
and
all the time these ice gullies are created and
they are also very important because,
for example, they increase the
thickness of the ice that is not important later in the
summer for the question of how  quickly
as it melts then it is so that
these ridges behave a bit
like sails and also the
keels of these ice ridges of course they
increase the air resistance then what you
unfortunately don't see that well now is that
um that's a picture of  an
ice ridge from below so shot from our
underwater vehicle and
you can see that these impressions me
now that they are not compact
but that there are spaces and
gaps everywhere where creatures such as
fish and plankton
can look for hiding places and then  once
again to this ice gullies which I
had already shown, they are a
bit like windows between the otherwise
very well separated
components ocean and atmosphere and
through these windows a lot of
heat and moisture gets into the
atmosphere that is you can imagine
just imagine that the iron, i.e.
ice, is a very large insulator that
you might know from the iglo and if
the ice thinks about it then
this exchange cannot actually
take place between the two
components, but if we
have this formation of back memories, we have
a lot more  Exchange and that means
that we also have a lot more new
ice formation in these channels, that
is, if you just want to take a picture of it with you,
the ice inside grows
about like bamboo while then
on the thicker ice areas that  he is such
a bonsai growth so there is a
big difference and that of
course also changes the ice thickness in
the Arctic again and one of the questions
we just looked at their music
was whether this process
is actually important for the entire
mass balance and for that  I just wanted to show you
really completely new
research results. We
looked at the ice thickness during the
Mosaic and saw how it
changed and you can see that a
bit from the pictograms here. We
initially had a relatively even
surface and then a lot of it
Processes that you saw in the video,
how the ice ridges piled up
and the gullies opened up and
especially in spring we had a
lot of this formation of races which then
immediately began to recede again because
the ice pushed together again and
we could see that  those
gutter training really made up 30 percent
of our total mass balance i
would say that's
a big enough number to say yes
this process is important indeed
and helps us understand a bit further this
system arctic yes more than tickets
but now back to
this one  Graphic the process I just
presented will not
lead to this count of this this
tendency to change more than decrease
that actually I would say
only we as a society if we
decide for a climate friendly neutral future and maybe  as a
motivation for our future, so our
current research shows that this
decline is more than a reversible
process, meaning if we
have lower effective temperatures again,
less greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
then we can actually reverse this trend
and I would say that
is definitely  If motivation enough to
really give it our all,
thank you very much Luisa for your presentation
and also for the beautiful pictures and the
film excerpt and also for this
background noise that we
were allowed to hear there are questions from you
that almost reminds me of them
Plate tectonics the processes you
describe are you there in exchange with your
colleagues from geology
geometology yes, I would say that
a lot of our yes more than
theory in relation to these processes
actually comes from plate tectonics,
so there are definitely two
Research areas that
talk to each other very well, that are time-conscious,
are completely different, that is, that
sometimes happens within a
few hours, of course,
plate tectonics also acts for much longer, there are
further questions, which
can still be curious questions, what is the most
dangerous or on  The
most exciting thing in the Arctic was
Mr. Zimmer, thank you, you said we can
reverse the process, very nice to hear,
I think we have to
keep our optimism, but where is the
temperature limit that we
have to comply with or that we
have to reach again for it to
be reversible?  you there
have models for you already have findings so
actually the current state
of research is that the practical
linear connection is between CO2
concentration in the atmosphere and more
than coverage so every ton that is
less in the net in the atmosphere
really
helps us more than  to stabilize the coverage again,
there are of
course processes such as how much
more than we need to really
get the ecosystem there, um, in the form we have it now,
I'm not quite there, I ca
n't say exactly, but it  it's true
of course that there are other things
to think about that we don't
fall below a certain limit
there was just another question when you
look back on the time on the
Polarstern what is that one feeling
you had the whole time or  what
usually comes to your mind
just to have something like that with you
I think it is this feeling of
being the only one there so this vastness
it is unbelievable when you are so far
away from all human
settlements and only there as a small group
to be and then simply experience nature
in a completely normal and much more
intensive way
because it is clear the
moment you leave the ship
you actually leave your
safe, protected space and are in
an environment that is definitely
Minus 42 degrees is not livable I get cold straight away Do you have
any further questions?
There is a
microphone.
Thank you very much. My question is,
are
all Antarctic residents involved in this research network, or
how is it composed now in
the expedition? Mosaic
yes Mosaic but of course  also going
beyond that because yes, if I am
following this correctly, the economic
interests in the environment are also very
pronounced and there are more yes I would
say there are voices who say the
Northeast Passage and other things
can give others can just
be used accordingly economically and that
could  yes lead to the fact that the
research activities are more likely to be
reduced and he the
activities in other areas are increased
yes so now Mosaic was I would say
an expedition that can
really be counted more in basic research
so there was little there so I was
n’t aware that  there was also
concrete research in relation to how
we can
use infrastructure in the Arctic, for example. It
was really a very international
conference and I would say that
all the major neighboring countries were
involved, including Russia, and
how these results are of course now
being used  that is again there is
on a completely
different sheet and they are of course
also publicly available so we um they
say that this is
of course the next step what is
derived from political actions
now and you can do that  both in the
sense of a one of a very protective
interest is to be interpreted and
of course in relation to an
economic use of the is
a question is up there I'm still coming
I saw you too late
to talk about the
research trip again it said
that  over a period of
the year there were around 400 researchers
who were always on board at the same time,
or did it change at some point?
we actually changed, so there
were five sections of the journey and between
these sections of the journey there were
always the researchers, so actually
everyone became everyone  on board were
exchanged on board of political
are about 100 people normally
and erm exactly then was exchanged but there
were also people who were there
several times so there are some you there
will have participated in up to three bike sections
so I myself
impressive yes but otherwise it was
changed and I think the number of these
400 actually includes
people who perhaps didn't
ride at all but were very closely involved in the
logistics and helped
to provide instruments and yes
on site then
I think that is again very important
because you can yes if  you realize you
've forgotten something you ca
n't just go to the hardware store quickly
it was also mentioned earlier
to buy it so there's really
an enormous logistical
planning effort behind it
there are more questions
one is back there
not that it's me  would have been aware,
of course, people were instructed
in advance and somehow trained
to use and take over certain instruments,
but in fact
our internet connection was
at least not so stable that
you could have done something via video now,
so that
actually tends to be limited  more on e-mails
with only text and no pictures and none so
good so no further
communication
phone is also a satellite phone
that is not such a stable connection
now to the outside world that it
would have worked up to now, at least for us
okay I don’t see any other hands up
and then I would say we are at the
end and I would like to thank
our four scientists very much
for the exciting
lectures for an insight into the
research and also for the presentation of
how important marine research is, I
believe that it was wonderfully
successful too  many thanks to the Berlin
science week to the entire organization
and of course many thanks to you who
were here for your interest for your
time for your questions if you
have any further questions please contact
us and the
scientists I will say that now
just like that
and then if you
still haven't had enough of marine research
or if you are now really interested
in marine research then
I also recommend the
next slot here today at the Berlin
science week I have to take a quick look at my
slip of paper it is  from the
Federal Ministry of Education and
Research the BMWs
is also one of the front-runners of the
German Marine Research Alliance and
has also
funded or at
least co-funded all the projects we heard about today and the topic is
fascination with marine research Europe's
mission to protect the seas and
waters have
fun  at the event
today and have a nice weekend
and maybe see you next year thank you very much
[applause]